welcome to this video playing sorry Dale
hmm yeah this is the guy that I beat
just two games ago but it was this very
narrow finish time wise if i'm not
mistaken okay I'll play this wacky h6
line again it's interesting I have tried
it before ya an online chess but player
unfortunately it was against a player
who cheated let's see what happens here
this line is so it doesn't really have
an official name but i call it the bull
mark in variation as a russian GM
vladimir bookmark ino plated really lots
of times okay so we have a pretty
standard position now it's um it's a
typical position for rookie six must be
conscious here a bit yeah it's not it's
not working but hmm cautious rookie 6f
equi ji six checking e7 and then some
let's say there must be a very tricky
position okay um should I go with Bishop
d6 this night at five so probably Bishop
e7 or B should be 4k Bishop e7
yeah okay come on this is a fatty fatty
sonic position lek doesn't have anything
particular to fear but it's not active
not reactive of course a 5 that is to
play a for Queen a 5 activating the
Queen gaining a bit of space on the
queenside it's one possible idea to to
activate pieces one problem is I don't
really have a good square for the queen
of the structure and if I have ever done
a five it's not in the way Queen a five
month sometimes Queen a six-point be
five what what I need to be cautious
about to see you shouldn't ever play d5
opening it up like to prevent that but I
have so many pieces on d5 at the points
of d5 is hard to play so you can leak
and try to do something on the King side
but it's not easy without them without
the light squared Bishop this is strange
move what exactly is it is the idea what
Bishop h6 I have 94 I this is not not on
at all so i can i can continue with this
idea add g5g five I have Bishop e7 wow
this is a bit lucky d5 otherwise g5 was
it would be interesting yeah ed 5
Queenie 70 and CD CD CD 9555 okay he
just wants to put it only five
okay I'd like to have Bishop f8 just
just being secure him that he cannot
second age six g5 wasn't an idea I think
he can take on d7 and get new square on
e5 sure Wow oh this is terrible I didn't
I didn't I didn't think about this move
at all oh ok at least I don't have much
choice or kim i didn't I don't forget
who i'm losing but it it's probably this
there is something night f5s under the
obvious obvious plane but if I go if I
go it should be for here Bishop before I
taking the Queen probably Bishop d6
takes Queen takes King of seven mother
is no mate ok show me how you win I
don't see it at the moment yeah still a
shelf at least consider to check this
but I didn't yeah well here I don't
really see the attack it's not it's not
even threatening a check here it's am of
course still a bit precarious but still
I don't I don't see it Queen g3 yeah
that's it settles attacking here and
introducing 96 how to defend our queen
g7 is also made
I take
Jack and probably Here I am rookie 7i
need two sec the queen but I have lots
of lots of little stuff planned for the
Queen check okay this this I didn't
really consider but of course he can
just take it for the moment shanks porn
check young king oops king yeah I need
to protect the seventh wrongly
check at least I'm not have not far
behind on a clock this is a slight
slight hope okay to give this check is
there some way for me to to avoid the
draw which is completely uncalled for of
course but is there some way to to do it
King King age 7 I see he's got the
chicken and each I need to return it's
not much I can do about it check grawr
our third can I continue or is this
completely seconded to try it's got many
poems you know how many points is here
for the piece seven pounds I got three
pawns the King g8 is what I'm talking
about Queen takes Queen g7 at the end he
will play b3m I have fun oh I can go to
h7 Alice's this is possible look my bad
rupee son
hmm i don't really see how to avoid it i
mean i'm still were so good on our
Tehran and I'm still I'm still worse in
this position and I have no way to avoid
it really I think you know the comp
doesn't think I'm so much wasn't
interesting me enough but well I mean in
terms of avoiding a draw i would need to
go here and yeah well this is just jack
just insane i mean white has got seven
points I've got to pause so five phones
and the only up would be if my Knights
would be a much more active like on on
here and they're taking a porn or
something but not not like this just um
just a bad setup yeah deserve it it was
very dangerous i'm probably losing yeah
the compass has wide wins I completely
have completely overlooked might have
seven rook e8 was the various sloppy
move okay thanks for watching